hi everyone welcome to another wolf and
language designer view this is going to
be a pretty quick one I hope I think I
think so too several live streams today
um and this is the first of them all
right system modeling
yeah so there's only one new function
and this is called System model
calibrate and that basically calibrates
parameters in a model with data
that enables you to build what's called
a digital twin yeah yeah
um
let me ask a general question I mean the
the business about things like making
entities for system modeler that's
that's not part of this release is that
correct
no
is that moving along or is that stalled
I think it's stalled we need to
re-initiate that uh
we really need that and in the world of
llms and so on and that whole flow I
mean I assume that that
uh
so the Wolfram Alpha people need it
that's what you mean right
not really that's the no the point is
we can use it
the flow that we have we are
increasingly teaching llms to deal with
entities in Wilson language yeah but
this is not a repository of ready-made
models this is a repository of building
blocks for which you from which I
understand that but but I mean like like
to give you an example you know we had
an example from Nick
uh
yesterday something about the quantum
framework okay where using a so
Christopher built this thing that is a
way of making custom endpoints for
uh llms okay so this was I think done
using an endpoint specifically uh that
knows about our Quantum framework
okay and you could describe a Quantum
circuit in natural language and it would
make you a a Quantum circuit and then be
able to compute from it and I have to
believe we can do the same thing for
system modeling
right yeah you probably could I mean
because if you can build a programming
language that does it you can certainly
describe it in text
right you can describe it roughly and it
will give you starting points which is I
think what what is really useful and
then you tweak it up using you know
potentially using system modeler or
using code
does that make sense
yeah
I think it's really an important thing
and I think that the the enabling glue
if we had entities we could just do it
immediately
because I think so but but we'll we'll
pick another crack at it
I mean this is what we had hoped to do
right when we started working with
system modeler was to get a flow from
northern Alpha through system modeler
this is now a much richer way of
handling natural language descriptions
anyway let's let's come to what we have
to do specifically now
um
boy This is complicated wow
oh we don't usually do that of having
lowercase
first letters and names like this
no usually tend to uppercase them
yeah okay we can change it yeah
all right
so let's see the example
wow
why is this
okay so here we've got a model
and here we've got oh I wish you
wouldn't do this so putting these
multiple things in one cell please don't
do that
all right I'll fix it yeah
I think I mean unless unless it breaks
how we our example thing works no it
doesn't
okay you're usually the one that wants
it in one cell just because copy The
Click is easier but well okay fair
enough
I'm not very keen on it either I don't
particularly like multiple things so
okay
all right
so
what are the two numbers here for
inertia what does inertia two mean
it's a the modeler of this example used
that to call uh one of the parameters in
the model
yeah I understand but that parameter is
a two vector or something uh it's it's
the notion in this case the that's the
variable uh that we are trying to fit
and the parameter okay I'm I'm guessing
I don't know the details of this model
but I'm guessing there is an inertia one
and an inertia two okay but then the
first element looking at the big time is
that correct yes
okay is that obvious from this
uh is time always a parameter in these
things or could it be something
different I mean could it be
no so the system models always simulate
things over time
the parameters are parameters so they
don't vary with time in which we don't
call them parameters when they vary with
time
sorry but inertia two is a non-variable
parameter is that true right that's a
variable that's a variable that changes
in time and and also that so you're
answering different things there so
that's a variable not a parameter and
yeah yes and the last ones the other
ones are the parameters
oh
yes
um
sorry
uh
um
okay
uh
so
this is a variable
and
it appears so so what are you trying to
compute here
what is the difference between this
model and this model
the output model has calibrated
parameters they are consistent with the
data
so when you build models okay it's like
if you need to use a resistor
there is a parameter called resistance
but it has a default value all the more
all the components in System model has a
default value and I don't know how would
I look at this thing with how would I
look at the parameter values
should I say parameters or something uh
yes you can ask for parameter values uh
but first you need to load what
uh yes you can you can ask for parameter
values But first you need to load a
system modeling functionality
why what do I what do you mean I have to
load it yeah so the the symbol that's
what is it what is it what do you mean I
have to load it this symbol uh on its
own do this something like this yes yeah
why wouldn't that do it on its own
uh we haven't fixed that yeah so we'll
fix it yeah
okay the other thing that you haven't
fixed is this needs to have an
autocomplete if I give that picture
right see that
and I start typing here that should give
an autocomplete menu
why is this taking forever
okay
all right so this has inertia dot I
don't see an inertia two
uh because these are the parameters I I
misspoke Stephen it's a bit it's a
variable sort of things over time
parameters
system variables
okay
all right so now in what sense is this
so
so then you're calibrating resistor one
dot r
and damper
spring damper one whatever I mean it
would be nice wouldn't it have some
indication in the icon like like for a
neural net if I just say you know if I
say something like you know net model of
Lynette well you can open it up
and system modeler has all that full
drill down
okay let's look at that okay so I mean
because what this shows is that's an
uninitialized neural net which is
essentially but but it's still
initialized it's not uninitialized it is
initialized this is just yeah
you know so people build what we call do
physical model building
but they may not know how those
parameters that they use they might even
use symbolic parameters relate to the
real world parameters okay but this
again doesn't really have that
information right no I I thought it
would show
um
you know the components you know the
diagram as opposed to the icon but their
icon diagram was the same thing so there
was nothing more right I guess I guess
you get that tool tips over the
components but that's a little bit of
information
yeah but they don't give the values I
mean that whatever it was that you were
setting what system model is the tool
for that that we sell
yeah okay the for setting for doing what
for determining all those parameter
values I mean if you want a a GUI where
you can drill down and know the exact
structure where you can build it that is
the tool for that right I'm just trying
to understand in the obscurity of the
fact that I have an input here I have
this thing here and I appear to get the
same thing back
no I well that's the default thing you
know it's kind of like many things where
we have many of the things that we can
you know return so you can the the spec
up there you can tell you can get other
things like quality measures
you know you'll see that often you want
for instance confidence bands how is
this fitted model reproducing the data
right
but so here
the default is model to model
yeah so the default is that we create
excuse me why is this blank
what was black I mean there was a
progress mark it did nothing
[Music]
okay can you try again I think that's uh
but I can't interrupt okay should I just
try it again yep
why was it pink at the beginning yeah
there was something yeah I can look into
that as well
uh so the default is that we make a copy
of the model with the new parameters so
it's like getting a formula out
yeah why why is it connectioning as it
why is it kind of uh you can you can
make it you know you see what it's doing
it's got the little pulsification there
which happens when the when the number
first comes over you need plot range
padding to prevent it from from having
that little conniption when it when the
number first comes into range
did you see what I'm talking about
uh okay like an Adaptive French
no the frame should not move
right did you see what I'm saying the
frame should not move all right right as
it was it was wiggling around the frame
was wiggling around if you ask the
machine learning people they have a
solution to that okay
okay and this picture should look really
like the machine learning picture
am I making sense all right yeah I think
these fonts are a bit big
I think you know if if you're setting
more stuff
okay did you see what I'm saying that it
Wiggles every time did you see that do
you see do you see what it's doing all
right okay do you see what it's doing
yes yeah okay so it shouldn't do that
and it's doing that because it's leaving
more space when a number first comes in
and sticks out of the end
I see what I'm saying and that can be
fixed with plot range padding and that
steps had some kind of backtick after it
I believe
just details but we go right
okay
um so if you scroll down Stephen to the
next example there see that here's a
different output there you can see that
you get a
um a confidence bands
yeah
I think that's what as a function of
time yeah
I think that's the money shot that's
something that's the most important
thing people want but there's as you
could see up there there's a ton of
other things that you can get it's a
calibrated System model so let me do
that for this case
so that is saying instead of these right
now at the end so because that's like a
property
so yeah I can't get it from the model
itself I can only get it from the
calibration process is that correct
no this gets you an object where you can
get everything why is this Auto
completing wrong
because it's usually needs the
documentation build before it can do
derive the order completions
okay
so this is why does it have to look
why is this I mean the loss what what is
it now doing
it's not showing an increasing range
there
why is it I don't understand the steps
why is it keep why is it still running
do you understand what I'm asking yes I
think it's just uh
I don't think it's okay it crashed
brilliant it crashed crashed the colonel
that's what he was busy doing
it's not great
um
okay all right let's take a look at some
more your
thing
model predictive controller this is
there's no design change it's just
faster and better algorithms okay
obviously we need to know why it crashed
here
obviously
um
okay and then I mean this thing
gosh has a million options which I'm
never gonna understand
no those are properties
there's a million properties there's
very few options
and we probably will but that's part of
another discussion we should have you
know kind of introduce subsections in
notes so you can have options and
properties in separate I think we should
do that I think it's time
isn't that nice yeah it is nice but let
me understand what it is so as a
function of time
that's showing the data and then it's
showing
okay so those are values of inertia two
as a function of time and then this is
showing what the model is doing but I
don't understand what the bands are
doing
those are uncertainty for a function of
of time
it's like if you had an a round function
but the parameters
I don't understand in the end this thing
fitted certain parameters yes or no yeah
and so
you know so there's some uncertainty in
those parameters now what happened to
the result when you solve those
differential equations when you have
uncertainty in some of the parameters it
goes in
that's going to lead to a whole slew of
different solution tractors coming out
right
so this is the envelope of all those
solution trajectories exactly yes
confidence level confidence level
I mean it's interesting to do all too
that's a that's a different kind of
problem which is yeah
it's nice it's very nice
I still want to use this stuff for
something myself
how similar is this in the end to the
machine learning framework you know with
validation sets and so on
I mean
that you know the machine learning
framework is similar to the regression
framework right because it it sort of is
right and this is similar to both of
those because it sort of is
but that what's different here which we
haven't tackled before is that you're
minimizing an integral
where you have differential equation
constraints
yes you know in the other cases we
minimize the sum with algebraic
constraints typically right if you know
machine learning usually doesn't even
have constraints right they just I think
I think machine learning doesn't
typically have constraints
it has it has some
I mean it tries to use things like
normalization layers to not have things
blow up
it's different approach right right
and um uh you know so so this is this is
an example of dynamic optimization or
sort of in you know another level of
optimization if you like
to do this
right
but so
so for example the use of the term loss
here
is that has that always been used in
control theory or is that new to post
machine learning no no no it's been used
so that was so machine learning got that
from Control Systems well yeah this is
this is part of it it's not what you say
in statistics
yeah but they're kind of all the same
thing so this part of if you like
control is you know does have a name
it's called system identification and
it's a big kind of field in its own
right but that field itself basically
picked you know almost everything up
from statistics indeed but like the term
loss yeah I had not really heard that
term except in machine learning oh yeah
no so I was in a group where we were
sort of world experts on system
identification and we used losses
okay so that's not the time in
statistics since it's statistics it will
be residual or something like that
wouldn't it
uh no I mean you use loss function there
too
because you varied a loss function okay
you know and it's the same guy as
Stephen like Trevor Hasty what's the
statistics guide it became you know the
machine learning guy
yeah I mean I understand it's one of
these it's all the same thing in the end
right right um
so can we in fact use this here's a
question how does this relate to like
our reinforcement learning efforts and
things
that's that's to live you know
it's a little bit of a different angle
which we want to tackle as well
I think that there are two kinds of
things that we can do with re you know
with respect to to reinforcement
learning so for reinforcement learning
we need an environment where you can
learn from sure but you have one and
System model because you have the actual
exactly so I think that that is a use
case
okay so so we need to package it up so
that one can take those things and kind
of learn from
right remember what you've got here is
your model here is differential
equations yeah in typical machine
learning nowadays the model is a bunch
of neural Nets or a neural net yeah and
so in principle you could have a version
of this you know calibrated whatever it
is
where
we could do also in a way I mean
interestingly we could for this very
function here in principle I could do
reinforce you know sort of
I could fit differential equations to
differential equations
okay so if I have instead of finite
measurement data Maybe I have a really
high fidelity
physical model
yep and now I want to calibrate a much
simpler physical model
but I want to get the best one
the one that approximates it the best
you know in this you know sense that I
defined the losses
well okay but I mean guess what I'm
asking is is there a way with our
Frameworks
to say
instead of
there being a differential equation
inside of the system model there's
actually a neural net inside of the
system model and it's just a model
calibration calibrate would basically
train the neural net instead of we don't
know the ode no but formally you can
include a neural net
in system models we added Onyx support
so if you can represent your neural net
as an onyx
neural net then it can be part of a
system model
which we can supposedly export to but
exactly a bit of a floppy fat format so
right
um
okay all right well
looks good I mean I I think it will be
really worthwhile to understand this
Plumbing you know given that we have a
you know well-developed neural net
machine no no I mean we we are aware and
we are talking to each other repeatedly
and so okay you know but this is this is
an important use case that this is their
addresses
um yeah as you can imagine yep here's
another cool thing which I'm sure that
you thought of but you're gonna call it
something else and I'll be Keen to hear
what you call it
yeah okay so let's say that I'm
observing a system I'm taking
measurements from some of its variables
okay and I do I run the system calibrate
that will you know estimate and
correctly you know correctly calibrate
some of the parameters
maybe what I really wanted to find out
was the parameter because that is what
it's something internal to the model
like viscosity inside of the system that
I couldn't measure
sure
okay so this is a way to build a sensor
in fact many sensors work this way that
you compute your way to
yeah whatever they call virtual what are
they called even virtual sensors what
are they called there's a name for that
yeah
and so that's that that might be itself
something interesting right that is
interesting that's quite interesting and
it's um
yeah that's quite interesting all right
well cool stuff
okay I don't think there's any more we
need to go over with this right now that
was it
okay I'll Roger I'll see you in another
half an hour or something at another
design review okay
okay thanks System model Control Systems
folk thank you good work okay see you
bye